ils veulent défendre leur trésorerie ce
matin à auxonne élus et habitants sont
venus protester contre le plan de
restructuration des finances publiques
qui prévoit la suppression de dizaines
de trésorerie dans la région les élus
estiment qu'elles sont indispensables
dans leur quotidien tout ce qui est
administratif c'est tellement compliqué
maintenant il ya tellement de choses à
savoir
on ne peut pas tout savoir et comme ça
on a le conseil qu'il faut et ça
facilite au niveau découle surtout ça
facilite au moment du budget on nous dit
qu'il y aura des tirages des maisons de
services au public il y aura des
permanences mais des permanences oui et
ce deux heures par semaine et cela
semaine entière
on ignore bonjour mesdames vous avez eu
une information par rapport à la
fermeture de la trésorerie d'auxonne et
deux des trois quarts de trésorerie pour
faire entendre leurs revendications une
pétition circule
elle a déjà recueilli 3000 signatures en
côte d'or
beaucoup d'habitants 10 se rendre
régulièrement à la trésorerie sa
disparition inquiète
ça va changer pas mal de choses parce
que moi j'ai l'habitude d'aller ici donc
j'ai pas de moyen de locomotion pour mon
aller ailleurs donc c'est un beau coup
de change et celle des factures à
l'année à un glitch pas comment je vais
faire
la solution envisagée par le
gouvernement c'est d'effectuer les
démarches uniquement sur internet
les syndicats s'y opposent une certaine
marge de la population d'un certain
cette commune les personnes qui n'ont ni
internet ni ordinateur et aucune
compétence en la matière donc qu'ils
seront obligés de se déplacer faire 30
40 km pour payer certaines choses ou
pour trouver une réponse par une grève
des finances publiques est prévue le 16
septembre prochain au niveau national